hola a todos soy shalkan de khan academy
como pueden darse cuenta estoy de
regreso en el lugar donde comenzó khan
academy esto es socialmente aislado y
seguramente muchos de ustedes también lo
están debido a esta crisis global que
estamos atravesando y si hay un lado
positivo es que estamos pasando por esto
todos juntos hay básicamente tres cosas
en la mente de todos primero y más
importante la salud y el bienestar
asegurarnos de que permanezcamos seguros
y saludables tanto como podamos la
segunda es la economía y la tercera es
que hay más de mil millones de niños
alrededor del mundo que si no fuera por
este virus irían a la escuela pero ya no
están asistiendo y es en esto en lo que
khan academy esperamos poder apoyar a
todos ustedes estudiantes padres y
profesores a nivel mundial
khan academy es una organización sin
fines de lucro con la misión de ofrecer
una educación de primer nivel para
cualquier persona en cualquier lugar
siempre hemos tenido la visión de que
todas las personas del planeta deberían
de ser capaces de desarrollar su
potencial
tanto desde el jardín de niños o incluso
antes en preescolar y avanzar por temas
de primaria secundaria preparatoria e
incluso de los primeros años de
universidad en matemáticas en las artes
del lenguaje en humanidades en ciencias
de manera que alcancen su potencial y
que puedan hacerlo a su propio ritmo y
aunque ninguno de nosotros pudo haber
previsto esta situación nos encontramos
ahora construyendo una organización que
creemos que puede apoyar a muchos de
ustedes en estos momentos hace unas
semanas cuando nos dimos cuenta de que
estábamos en esta posición todos
nosotros en khan academy comprendimos
que es nuestro deber redoblar esfuerzos
para ustedes estudiantes profesores y
padres del mundo por eso estamos
haciendo todo lo que está a nuestro
alcance más allá de los recursos que
mencioné antes para apoyarlos de la
mejor manera estamos haciendo
conferencias en línea en inglés para
padres y profesores estamos
transmitiendo en vivo todos los días
también en inglés para que podamos
sentir que estamos todos conectados
conforme atravesamos esta crisis
juntos quiero recordarles que somos una
organización sin fines de lucro nuestros
fondos vienen de donaciones
filantrópicas por lo que si te
encuentras en una posición para hacerlo
por favor considera hacer una donación a
khan academy a las personas en tu región
que están trabajando en la localización
y la traducción a tu idioma hay más de
40 proyectos de traducción alrededor del
mundo con el fin de poner khan academy
al alcance del mayor número de personas
posible gracias por escucharme espero
que esto nos ayude a atravesar la crisis
en algunos aspectos a pesar de los
complicados e inusuales que son estos
momentos estamos juntos en esto somos
seres humanos y he visto que todos están
tratando de hacer lo correcto para sí
mismos sus familias y todo el planeta
creo que vamos a salir de esta juntos a
pesar de lo mala que pueda parecer la
situación creo que está con actividad
puede ser muy muy poderosa